this is what happens projects more and
more in my life choose me when I'm ready
when something has happened or you know
something I've reached a certain level
of understanding about this world or
something that that the ideas seem to
find me you know
the perfect thing so this is the perfect
thing ET spoke with Carrie at the
premiere of kidding his new Showtime
series debuting September 9th
[Music]
this show can get so heavy sometimes and
it deals with death a lot out of you
what was it that you brought to this and
how do you how did you process all the
stuff with the death you know I mean the
way we do we you know nobody gets
through this life without getting hit by
lightning you know and that's just you
know is the lightning gonna be something
that causes a fire it's are you gonna
stop there at the fire they're thinking
that it was just a disaster or are you
gonna continue on to see the new growth
and that's that's kind of what this is
about its new growth I want to ask you
about your painting because you heard
very talented artists what are you what
inspires you to paint and would it and
will you one day just let this go and
just paint 24/7 it's it's I'm always
painting or sculpting whether it's
acting or anything else it's all the
same thing to me so you know I took a
little break from the acting and you
know what happens is something else pops
up you know I need an outlet of
creativity but it does it's like water
it just flows into another area and
gives that a chance to flourish and then
I come back with a new trick and I can
do the old stuff too hi I'm viola and by
the way people are always talking about
these revivals is there any chance that
you call the waiting's one day and you
guys do some living color you bring it
back through you bring it back around it
really needs to happen that show needs
to exist again universally now
especially now man there's so much to
eat up and spit out you know so I'd love
to see it reconstitute itself in another
form you know I go back and hang out
with them would you sure of course I
would we will start that fire tomorrow
at the door for me
you